movie lovers from around the globe go to
see movies to experience a full range of
emotions to laugh to cry to escape
ultimately to be told a good story we
want to see compelling characters go
through the dynamic range of human
experiences spanning from Joy and guilt
to Triumph love
the nominees in the next category come
to us from Poland Belgium Argentina
Ireland and Germany
although these filmmakers may be from
different countries and cultures they
have proven that the language of
Storytelling is universal
nominees for best International feature
film
for Germany All Quiet on the Western
Front directed by Edward Berger
from Argentina Argentina 1985 directed
by Santiago Mitre
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to
Edward Berger all quiet
this is the 12th nomination for Germany
and third win All Quiet on the Western
Front is the eighth non-english language
film to be nominated for both
International feature film and best
picture in the same year
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
thank you
God this means so much to us so I met so
many new friends on this movie my
cinematographer James friend who's won
an Academy Award my costume designer
Lizzy Crystal my production designer
um Christian Goldberg my hair and makeup
designer hike America and I owe
everything to you I owe everything to
you and the rest of my crew but the
other day I walked into a brunch here
and I met another cinematographer James
don't don't it's not another movie and
it was Florian Hofmeister who was also
nominated for an Academy Award for tar
and we held each other we're from the
same town we held each other and for 30
years we made our first movie together I
was his assistant and
um we held we held each other and for 30
years it felt like there was an Embrace
of all the hard work that went into this
and it's just deeply moving for for all
of us thank you Netflix for supporting
us thank you uh to my wife and my kids
uh thank you Ted sarandos Sasha Bula
Scott stuber and David Carsey for making
our movie thank you mount agrunner these
two wonderful actors
my producer Daniel bruel and Alberto the
actors and especially Felix Cameron
this was
this was your first movie
this was your first movie and you
carried on us on your shoulders as if it
was nothing without you none of us would
be here thank you Felix
[Applause]